hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on foreigner again
today we're gonna do a little bit of a
shorter video I actually planned on not
making this video but I thought that you
guys deserve one anyway because there
was a lot of things that I needed to
make sure that you guys knew for today I
also want to apologize that this [ __ ]
this video should have been out a lot
earlier but I had to go pick something
up for my professor at school so that
was definitely of utmost importance
because that would have been very
terrible but um with today's video we
got a road map and some other
information especially with the new
season launching so let's get started
the first up actually has to do with the
road map and this is going to be the
road map for November essentially
there's really not much going on for
November 7th we have the launch which is
today next week on the 14th is going to
be spectator mode beta launch with an
arcade quest the 15th which I believe is
going to be a Friday of next week that's
going to be a range of anguish or
challenge with some XP booster wards as
well as on the 21st being arcade in
content 22 being an extra XP fest with
some more challenges and the 28th being
up somewhat important because it is
hyper duel again but also on top of that
we have the white materials the stuff we
talked about in the past of it couple
videos this week the white materials are
actually coming to the game so if you
hop on during the launch of the game you
know what soon dot being the new
character I don't actually know at the
time of this recording if the season is
live they might be still [ __ ] with
the servers at the moment but if you hop
on at any point definitely check your
main and your characters and try to buy
the white material if you have the steel
for it or if it matches your character
cuz it'll actually looks really really
cool and then on top of that lastly we
have the twitch soon viewer rewards
essentially I've been talking about this
all the time going from November 7th to
November 14th if you watch any four on
our stream or hopefully you've included
me in that list then you're going to be
getting some sort of xp rewards and
scavenger crates and steel with I
believe the first hour being something
around the lines of one XP boost with 24
hours it being something around like
4000 steal a couple of scavenger crates
and combat packs a lot of nice [ __ ]
there and you don't have to continuously
watch 24 hours it just has to be 24
hours of make of accumulated time within
that week and all you have to do is just
link your Uplay account or your Ubisoft
account and stuff to your other accounts
like your Xbox or Playstation so console
this works for you guys and it works for
PC if that sounds a little bit confusing
and you'd have never done this before
just definitely go into the description
and
go to my twitch and if I am
live-streaming which I plan on
live-streaming after this video is live
if not then it's I'm if I'm not
streaming it's most likely because the
server's aren't up but if I am streaming
when you click that link just ask me in
chat and either me or someone in chat
will help you out I bet I was helping
out tons of people last season and I'll
do it again because we all need those
awards but that's all that I thought was
going to happen the streamers would be
getting rewards too for streaming in the
viewers of beginning rewards for viewing
for an accumulated time but there's
actually a whole lot more if you end up
actually watching so November 11th and
November 12th and November 13th which is
the last technically the last three days
but there's also the 14th of November
you're going to be getting specific
rewards which is basically all XP boosts
depending on what time you watch it so
on November 11th if you're watching at
12:00 p.m. Eastern Standard Time or at
3:00 p.m. Eastern Standard Time you're
going to be getting for XP boost on
November 12th it is the same thing and
the same on November 13th I don't know
if it has to be anywhere between those
three hours or if you check in twice
then you're gonna get 8 XP boost but if
you check in around those times it's
gonna be a load of XP and if we actually
add these up that's 8 16 24 XP boosts
which is insane but even if that's not
the case it'll be 12 which honestly 12
XP boosts is [ __ ] wild so definitely
go hop in any of these streams I have
the thing on screen so you can look for
it for yourself and you can always come
back to check out this video and that's
how you're gonna be getting free rewards
for out the week and you don't have to
be playing you you literally can be at
work watching the stream it could be on
your phone you could be asleep whatever
it needs to be there's so many different
ways if you need help it just always
come into the stream and just ask me or
the chat and we'll help you out be I
liked if you do enjoy guys subscribe if
you're new I cover the informational
side a foreigner that being the balance
changes to hear updates the patch notes
and the leaks if we kept up today with
everything happening then the world of
foreigner and never miss out on an
update defeted subscribe to channel guys
take care have a great astir day
hopefully I see you in the stream and
peace out
you